okay let's uh refresh our discussion a
little bit about climate change being a
hoax created by the Chinese a comment
that Donald Trump really made front and
center at the first presidential debate
on Monday the backstory is multiple
times Donald Trump has tweeted this idea
that climate change is a hoax developed
by and for the benefit of the Chinese
Hillary Clinton called him out on that
during Monday's debate Donald Trump lied
saying no I never said that of course
the fact checkers very very easily found
uh the tweets where Donald Trump did
indeed say that that's all fun and games
compared to what I'm about to show you
here Donald Trump's campaign co-manager
Kellyanne Conway went on CNN and she
admitted something that should be
singularly disqualifying for someone who
wants to be effectively the most
powerful person on the planet in the
election that is up coming here she said
and it's hard for me to even believe it
that Donald Trump does not believe
humans are having any impact on the
climate change that we are seeing on our
planet this is not something that is in
the scientific consensus this is
something that is supported only by a
very very tiny fraction somewhere
between point three and two percent of
climate scientists believe this i'm
going to play the video for you and you
can see that Kellyanne Conway she sort
of seems to take a an attitude where she
realizes that this is not a good line of
questioning she's not handling this
particularly well but I think it's
because she accidentally told the truth
take a listen to this take clean energy
some country is going to be the clean
energy superpower of the 21st century
Donald thinks that climate change is a
hoax perpetrated by the Chinese I think
it's real I did not fansedge I do not
say that I think I do not see it so does
he think the climate change is a hoax or
not a hoax or it's real I think that's
based on a tweet and half right I just
love that that this this whole man
whether he's giving up yeah I guess so
answer to Howard Stern about invading
Iraq as a private citizen on an
entertainer radio show or through a
tweet we're supposed to understand all
those policies this woman proudly went
and can
to vote for the Iraq war in the well of
the Senate and she's been an
intervention all your advantage he's the
one who sends out the tweets I mean he
sends out what his thinking is on these
policies but the concept of global
warming was created and by and for the
Chinese and virginie US manufacturing
non-competitive I mean these are his
thoughts snowing in Texas and Louisiana
record-setting freezing temperatures
throughout the country and beyond global
warming is an expensive hoax does he
believe that global warming is a hoax he
believes that global warming is
naturally occurring is what is what
naturally naturally equipped that
climate change is naturally occurring he
believed your mission and that there are
shifts naturally occurring oh he doesn't
believe it's man-made correct so he
believes that the idea that it's
man-made as a hoax I know I didn't say
that I mean he said it I'm actually
repeating his tweets he believes that
that part is a hoax he believes that
climate change is naturally occurring
yeah but but but David both parties are
exactly the same Hillary and Trumper
exactly the same right yesterday Myra
Nevel climate science deniers was good
was was it was revealed he would be
heading Trump's EPA transition team and
now we learn and I have no reason not to
believe it correlates with everything
else that Donald Trump is set on the
issue that we have no reason to think
anything that we're observing on earth
now is it all impacted by human
activities this entire climate change is
not man-made thing is not one of these
small mistakes wrong type of things it's
I believe the earth is flat wrong that's
how I see it Rachel he has said that on
day one of his presidency he would
withdraw the u.s. from the Paris climate
Accords could he do it unilaterally I
don't know do you want someone being
president who would even try the answer
is no he said on day one he would lift
President Obama's executive order
halting construction of the Keystone
pipeline could he do it probably also
very disturbing there are real
consequences here yeah but he's at odds
with his own running mate because Mike
Pence went on CNN and said that humans
absolutely have had an impact on the
climate yes oh it's kind of interesting
that your own running mate is
disagreeing with you yet and i wish i'm
on numerous issues i remember when he
was asked about uh there was this really
awkward moment on 60 minutes and i am I
apologize I don't
I'm going to remember what it was I
think it was no was the Iraq war when
donald trump was asked i believe by
lesley stahl you know you slam Hillary
for her vote regarding the funding of
the Iraq war the guy sitting next to you
your running mate had the same vote what
do you say about that he says well
everybody's allowed to make mistakes
apparently not Hillary Clinton so yeah
Pence and Trump at odds on it on a
growing number of issues I'm sadly
afraid that because the anti climate
change science movement has been
relatively successful at promoting the
false idea that there's actually
controversy over this issue that this is
not going to be perceived as that
serious of an issue by too many voters
and that's really the sad thing here the
david pakman show is sponsored this week
by decode DC the podcast that gives you
an honest look into how politics affects
your life the host of the code DC is
Jimmy Williams and is a very interesting
guy he worked in politics on both sides
of the aisle starting as a Republican
becoming a Democrat his work as a
lobbyist he does know his stuff and he's
taking that experience and explaining
the internal dynamics of how Washington
DC works decode DC will often dig into
topics that you know I'm passionate
about money in politics for example
including a recent show about why small
dollar donors don't actually produce
winning political candidates check it
out I did I think you will love it we
are talking about decode DC it's
available on iTunes stitcher or wherever
you get your podcasts